Đừng kuyến trong băng ngày tại của la làm thương,
tuyến sẽ dự và phát biểu tại các phía n' học trong phương tổ hội hội hội các cơm cào a sàng bữa bài.
Các hội nghị cấp cào a sàng với các lối tác qua khi chúng quốc,
án độ, New Zealand, Australia, Nhật Bản, Khan Quốc, Bien Hoc,
Nhân dịm này, tuyến chính cú có các cộp trước súc sông phương với lãnh đạo khách nước.
Các cộp trước cú tế tham dự hội hội nghị và nhiều hạt động qua trong khách.
Trong sáng ngày hai mi sọ tháng bời, tuyến đã dự phía n khai mặt của hội các cào a sàng lên tủ mỗi mời,
và các khội hội cấp cào lối ngoan trong đó tủ bến cũng đã dự và tham gia lễ khi kết lịch sử,
tuyến bố kết nạp tìm mò lẽ s tê và a sàng cũng trong ngày hai mi sọ tháng bời,
tuyến phòng mình chính cũng đã gặp tổng thống Brasil, Nú la đặc sinh ba,
gặp tuyến cán là đá mắt hà này, thăm dự phía nổi thỏa các cào tại hội hội hội thượng bình kinh raen và đổ tuy a sàng a biết,
gặp có chút tịch vôn bánh phủ trách nông a thay bình dân dự đối thoải cấp cào tại hội hội hội thượng bình kinh raen đổ tuy a sàng.
Hối việc thăm dự hội hội hội cấp cào a sàng và các hội hội cấp cào lối ngoan,
về năm tiếp tục hợp lệnh sử tích cực thăm gia và nổ góc có chất nhận cho thành công chung của các hội hội,
tuy chì đoàn kết, nổng thận trong a sàng. Nổ góc cho công việc chung nhất là duy trì môi trường hoa bình,
or định của vực đã giảng hóa quan hệ và thị trường tăng cường kết lối a sàng.
Hội cấp mốt và đối tác của hợp với lệ của vực năng và lựa của a sàng và hòa bình an ninh phát triển ở cú vực và hình dựa.